Ian: Well asking what -- what's the one thing
you can do is a bit of a dumb question, it's
always a bit like asking do you want a heart
or do you want a lung, the answer is both.
But if I had to focus on one thing, I think
the world community has to concentrate on
not overreacting to issues.
So for instance, not reacting to the stock
exchange fall by overprotection.
To recognize what has helped the world community
and to continue with it, so it continues with
the critical long term issues.
So a real focus on the long term rather than
overreacting to the short term.
And the long term issues remain.
They remain poverty, they remain climate change
and they remain getting the best out of globalization.
That's what I would say, keep focusing on
the long term and don't react too much to
the short.
Thank You